dave is in san jose hi dave welcome to
the dave ramsey show
well i picked up the wrong one i'm gonna
there's dave hey dave how are you
hello there you are what's up man hear
me
loud and clear yeah so i'm 21
and i just graduated from uh college
and i started working good and i have no
student loans
no debt um and i have about a hundred
thousand of my savings where third
thirty thousand is my emergency fund and
the rest are diversified investment
where did you get all this
uh i worked uh during college i ate rice
and beans beans and rice
never went out uh worked super hard
so i saved up a lot and so
my question to you is that i've always
wanted to buy a house soon in the next
two
three years but houses here around one
to 1.5 million for a town home and so
the down payment is like 200 to 300 000
and so my question is is it should i
continue to live right beans beans and
rice to save up for this down payment or
is it okay for me now financially
to splurge a little bit and maybe buy
myself
a car that i've always wanted
well to start with you're way ahead of
the game uh
and you know san jose is one of the most
expensive real estate markets in america
and so you're not you're you're not a
cheap area dude i mean you're a very
very expensive area
uh you've got plenty of time you're only
21. uh and so if i were in your shoes i
would buy a car what are you thinking
about buying
uh i'm trying to buy a tesla mm-hmm
and what's that those are around
them yeah so those are around like uh 30
to 50
000 okay and that's out of your cash
some of your investments will go to that
full cash yeah and um
what do you make i make 160 000 a year
okay what do you do a software developer
no shock okay and in san jose and 21.
okay wow okay so yeah buy the tesla
and uh it fits in this and then you then
you go back to saving
here's the thing you're on what we call
baby steps four through
seven and that's where you're 15 of your
income going into retirement
and uh you can stop that for a little
while if you want to and save for a
house we call that baby step 3b
um and if you want to do that that's
fine but there is no requirement of
beans and rice rice and beans when
you're at this stage yeah
you you go from intensity intensive
intensity
gazelle intensity to intentionality
i just want you now to be intentional
just be paying attention which i don't
think you're gonna do anything but that
no and you need to relax and start to
have some fun dude you're gonna snap
and go buy like nine things or whatever
have some fun but you need to be
prepared
are you ready to stroke a check for 50
000 i mean you got to be aware of this
and really acknowledge that bank
account's going to be a whole lot
lighter
make a decision be clear
yeah well you're it fits everything
we're talking about to do to go that
route yep and you've got plenty of time
to save up then
and do things for your uh for your house
after that
so good stuff well done this is the dave
ramsey show